he's back
but
semadar is someone here
it's nothing she doesn't need to know
tell her it's nothing Bob what is it hon
nothing Lindy just go back to sleep okay
I need to let the dog out he was a storm
I'll take care of it
it wasn't just your imagination
he was real you know it that was a sound
you've not heard since how long has it
been months years maybe could it have
been that long everything seems so
distant as if you're coming awake from a
perpetual dream what's happened to you
Bob
where have you been you try to remember
you got here into this house but it's as
though you're looking at your memories
through someone else's eyes only you
know you heard the laughter so sound you
promised yourself you'd never forget no
doubt about it
the void has returned
after all this time somehow he's found a
way back to earth you can imagine we can
see him hiding in the storm
that's just how he'd make his play if it
is the boy he'll be stronger than ever
before the danger will be beyond measure
and there will only be one hope for
Humanity you
startling stories featuring the Sentry
with the power of a million exploding
Suns you asked for lore leaders
introducing the greatest hero of them
all the golden guardian of good are you
ready for the secret of the century
in today's episode Robby discovers the
professor secret formula gosh
this must be the professor secret
formula gosh you think this must be the
professor secret formula we must be
vigilant watchdog we are we're
humanity's only hope
suddenly a miraculous transformation
takes place the boy glows with an
unknown energy using his newfound powers
meek young freshman Robby Reynolds the
century counters the blow swiftly
that'll put it into your bullying buzz
gosh I used to think buzz was such a
dreamboat but now I can scarcely believe
it I think I'm falling for Robby
not evening the resourceful freshman
puts the finishing touches on the
marvelous golden suit he's fashioned
would it buzz love but I know real then
so are me your golden suit hangs in
there untouched since the last day you
were here the void truly has returned
you'll have no choice bottom you're
going to have to learn again
I'm going to have to become a century
the super serum it's been years since
you it's been years
it comes over you a rush more wonderful
an unutterable force like a million
little exploding Suns
that feels so good and then the memories
flow welcome thoughts of Glory's past
this is if you just open a surprise
package you send yourself in the mail
meanwhile the golden guardian of good
leaps to the air impervious to the
effects of the elements around them my
sensory sensors tell me the blue buffoon
has attacked Empire State University I
must alert spider-man little does you
suspect robbery riddles and a century or
one of the same you remember a picture
an iconic image that even you are proud
of you're not supposed to be proud this
different the photograph is a reflection
of you
it's encapsulation of your benevolent
intent that sent six billion people
safely into dreamland over time you
watch over the world it is your sworn
duty we must be vigilant watchdog for we
are humanity's only hope no that that
didn't happen did it it was a it was in
a comic book you read when you were a
kid or on a TV show but the void Israel
he has to be
you know among us as well as you know
yourself what's wrong with you why is it
so hard to remember as a stunned Avenger
struggle to break free
even Iron Man's amazing suit is no match
for the voice cosmic cocoons blast you
void let us go oh not a chance Iron Man
with the Avengers held captive surely
the mighty century will soon follow but
suddenly with the power of a million
exploding Suns sooner than you bargained
for void ha
I will return century I will return I
will turn he always said that even when
you thought him beat forever he said it
and he always kept his word something is
happening something indecipherable you
can no more describe it and swallow your
own throat it's there right in front of
you
why can't you see it are you the serum
creates a phase shifting effects in the
molecules of your body causing each item
to shift an instant ahead of the current
timeline listen to me century it's
important that you understand and
somehow the serum induces a
photosynthetic reaction creating a hyper
state of consciousness I've heard the
old man harp on us so many times I could
have recited his spiel backwards my
powers come from the Sun Eva the boy
knows that
cut to the chase professor do I win the
prize or what in effect your powers are
limitless boy there is nothing you
cannot do you've conquered the time and
space itself you are omnipotent good
morning immortal it sounds like a dream
you once had and remember it there was
more I got to get back Richards is
waiting for me there's been a real
professor no wait listen to me rod we
have no way of knowing what will happen
after prolonged usage of the serum it
was never meant to be used in this way
according to my calculations every time
you boost the dosage must be increased
there's a danger you're becoming
dependent on the drug too late professor
in case you forgot I've got a galaxy to
save dependent or not you never really
had a choice always the boy and always
you as a last line of defense
you'd gain after every turn but it was a
game you realize you could never win and
now he's coming back you can feel it
it's not just your imagination isn't
it's broken but you can fix it
the conflictive was the only working
relic left on the temporal long
homeworld after the Boyd attacked you
may decide on promise in their memory
that you use a device to defeat him once
and for all he's gone now away from the
daylight he'll be lurking on the dark
side of the planet finding its time
until the night chases them back here
again if you can repair the conflictive
before then it'll keep him disoriented
for a while
it's no use your once sharp
scientific mind doesn't what it used to
be you need something to help you focus
the Super's here has been years it's
been years it comes over you now hard to
keep it together that's just the effect
of the super serum sometimes it does
this counteract the poison who told you
that it was someone you knew someone you
trusted we must be good
you call that vigilance century you
shouldn't have opened your door to me
Robert I told you I would return get
away you're not real
pathetic dirty little junkie did you
really think you could send me away
forever and what then
no more sensory to soothe humanity's
fevered brow there is no century there's
no void they don't exist anymore
liar I am all things I Lavoie I am the
face of your soul your wife is the void
your house is the void you are the void
no you're not real what the hell's going
on what do you got almighty Bob did you
kick the dog no yeah I mean it wasn't
him Lindy not the dog
it was the void he's come back
oh my god you stupid bloody idiot
is this what you're doing hiding it now
you don't even have the guts to ruin
your life in front of me anymore
how could you do it to me Bob you
promised you said you'd quit drinking it
was just another one of your stupid lies
I don't know if I can take this anymore
you promised me you'd get some help you
said you'd go to AAA I've been thinking
I might go to Judy's for a few days I'll
take the animals with me let her go it's
better that way she doesn't understand
okay
okay that's all you've got to say okay
let her go she's forgotten who you
really are
should we save her if she doesn't
remember it's better this way
no one remembers except you you are hero
and your life was a fabulous
rollercoaster ride of daring an
adventure you and the others heroes you
were all that stood in the way of evil
there you remain until it went away but
the end of every ride is always the
beginning of another you must have
suspected it would one day come to this
but you'd have to wear the century suit
again God you think it feels good to put
the old suit on again the centrosome
your people haven't forgotten you they
need you what's more into the breach for
Humanity see once more
century
now is the time for vigilance